- What's your favorite Halloween candy,
like to trick-or-treat?
- My favorite
Halloween candy is one
that we have in New Zealand
called Pineapple Lumps.
I actually love Pineapple Lumps.
- It's called Lumps?
- Yeah.
I know, they need to
work on their branding,
I think, a little.
- Okay, I was like marketing.
Okay, I wanna try, pine...
I wanted to try your favorite
thing so I'm going to...
Oh my God.
(laughing)
I hadn't seen you yet.
- Look at the service.
- They, okay, okay.
- Oh my goodness.
Oh, for me all?
- Oh my God.
I feel like we're on Indiana Jones.
- This is great.
- Okay.
- Very cool.
- Okay, wait, I'm gonna
put this right here.
You can put yours down if you'd like.
Oh, that was a cooler spot, yeah.
- I've chosen a really
precarious spot.
- I'm gonna try it.
Okay, well, wait.
- What do you think?
- Okay, it's a lot tougher.
- Yeah.
- Than I anticipated.
- I think these have been
refrigerated actually.
- Okay.
(giggles)
I was like, that was tougher.
- Mm, very chewy.
Mm, tastes like home.
- So it's like,
a chocolate-covered gummy bear, kind of.
That's delicious.
- Mm, thank you.
- It's like taffy, like
chocolate covered taffy, almost.
- Mm hmm.
- Okay, I like that.
I'm leaving that there or
I won't be able to talk.